hello everyone
so this is my last video for this year
2021 and i thought of making it on a
topic which is very much close to all of
you heard and that is on the topic of
returning to campus
my understanding is that a number of
institutes across india are planning to
bring the students back to their campus
and some of the institutes may have
already done so and some institutes even
if they have not not informed their
students till now they are i'm sure uh
planning intensely to bring the students
back and god willing if the influence of
micron is not too heavy uh
i mean
all students should give back to the
campus in the next few months so fingers
crossed
okay so
these students who are about to come
back to campus i'm sure you are
receiving a lot of advice especially if
you're leaving home for the first time
and you do not want me probably to
repeat those pieces of advice
but i want to share a few thoughts with
you
which
go beyond the individual level and
addresses the collective psyche
this is something which is uh very very
close to my heart
and it's rather serious
so let's go about discussing it
you see
this uh whether you are in the second
year third year fourth year fifth year
and in some cases probably even the
first year students
you try to realize that you are standing
at a very very historically important
moment as you are about to return to the
campus
okay like there is an enormous
responsibility which rests on your
shoulders
you are the connection between the old
and the new you have to accept this
especially students who are in their
third year fourth year fifth year
you may have had glimpses of the age-old
traditions the innumerable little
experiences of student life the unsaid
uh
bonds of friendship friendship and
relationships which may have claims from
your seniors and now as you're returning
to campus you probably want to revive
them those age-old traditions amongst
yourselves and certainly you want to
also inculcate them uh in your
juniors and similarly the second year
students the first-year students when
you will be joining the campus for the
first time i'm sure you'll be waiting uh
impatiently to meet your
batchmates for the first time physically
you
also want to meet your seniors uh share
their experiences learn from them uh
listen to the many many stories from
them
get and get glimpses of the student
culture and overall be a part of this
entire student body okay and uh
i mean
trust me these are extremely important
things like these are the kind of things
which gives you a gen genuine sense of
belongingness to your institute much
much beyond which any official document
can convert to you i mean your institute
id is very important your role number is
important your institute email id is
very important but the genuine feeling
of belongingness you will feel only
after coming to the campus that simply
cannot be substituted for
okay so go ahead
soak in all those experiences from your
peers from your seniors
but before you can do that uh
i want you to pause a bit
okay pause for a moment
reflect ponder and think and question
that
when you are
about to go into this soaking up of
experiences
uh
do you really want to go back to the
age-old traditions blindly or do you
perhaps want to do it a little bit
better so as you're standing at the at
this cusp at this at this historically
important moment
can you perhaps not do something a
little bit better than before what do i
mean by that
okay so this is a great opportunity uh
for us to perhaps think about rolling a
new era
okay so what do i mean by all this
you see the you know
compared to the corresponding batches uh
of the pre-pandemic era your particular
batches are far more mature so this is
something which has life has conferred
on you
okay
so it's like this that sure
the previous batches and i was also very
much a part of them
of those batches
we also faced challenges but those were
the kind of challenges which were
confined within the protective confines
of our campus
those were like within set rules
set rules and regulations
we more or less knew what we were going
to face
uh it was as if in the examination of
our undergraduate life and i'm not
talking about actual exams and tests
okay in the examination of actual life
we always had the luxury of referring to
the previous year's question papers
you guys do not have that luxury there
is not there is no precedence for you as
you are standing at this historically
important moment okay so since we do not
have this luxury
i mean
and at the same time you have
experienced so much more uh
see
and it's really unfortunate that i have
to uh
that i that i say this
many many of you
have actually faced
heard about deaths of your near and dear
ones okay within your extended family
perhaps
and i'm quite sure that perhaps there
will not be a single student who within
his extended family or
his friend circle
somebody he or she knows they have not
heard of a certain death
okay or some kind of mishap some kind of
hardship they have not come across okay
there will not be a single student like
that
okay so these kinds of life experiences
they have conferred on you uh
i mean a certain hardened mentality a
certain hardened psyche which previous
generations of students
never had
okay so you are a very very special
batch
you have the kind of life experiences
which
which we did not never which we never
had ah
and perhaps hopefully your juniors will
also never have okay so you are like a
very very special spec mature
badge so my my invitation to all of you
my call to action to all of you is that
why not try to infuse this maturity
these life experiences this hardened
mentality uh into doing uh
things a little bit better than before
so i want to go into the specifics a
little bit more okay so i've been
talking in generalities till now
uh you see
uh previously when we used to grow up
from our first year within a campus uh
as we grew up there was a certain
uniformity in our mentality okay our
day-to-day habits sleeping habits eating
habits even our speaking habits okay
each campus has its own specific lingo
uh
so all these things imparted a certain
uniformity and
uh for good or bad uh it was like
uh there was almost an unsaid
expectation that
everybody will fall in line everybody
will be the same
uh
and when
when we okay when we also became seniors
there was like this unsaid expectation
like
we'll all be like this okay and without
much uh due thought being given to
individual differences and traits
and
we certainly for sure we never
actually thought about
mostly about the
the mental space which a person might be
when we kind of implicitly invited him
to partake in this rather uniform
student culture
now you guys have the richness of life
experiences which we do not have you
have that maturity far far greater than
we ever had
why not try to use this maturity these
life experiences to uh to revive the
student culture in a much much better
way that is my call to action for you
okay so
what i want to say here is that you
revive the student culture but do this
with a certain empathy a certain
kindness compassion okay be inclusive in
your efforts when you're trying to
uh maybe include or invite someone into
a club maybe into your friend circle do
not just blindly or implicitly uh uh i
mean kind of
like the
peer pressure kind of thing
force him to fall in line with your
expectations everyone is different
everyone has had some hardships in the
recent past respect that okay now
please don't mistake me for uh when i'm
saying all of these things please not
think that i'm just asking all of you to
turn into some kind of snowflake okay
that is not my intention
what i want you to do is to just think
about okay be a little bit more
sensitive
and
uh feel about
others
okay
i mean
a very important part of student culture
is
i mean
something as simple and trivial it may
seem is to engage in some kind of frolic
some activity make fun of others even
okay i'm not asking to stop those things
making fun of others frolic some
behavior banter this is all an integral
part of student life especially
undergraduate student life why just
undergraduate even at the master's level
i mean
okay you're young enough for all those
things so
engage in all those things but when
you're doing it
okay at the back of your mind be a
little bit empathetic towards your
fellows
okay so
i read this song at this great line that
when you're making fun of others
uh
don't make them feel that you are
laughing at them
rather try to uh
try to generate a feeling that you are
laughing with them okay there's a big
difference so that makes them feel a lot
more included that actually helps them
to partake of the fun even if the fun is
being made at their expense okay there's
a big big difference okay so i'm sure
your patches being more mature will be
able to appreciate this more
now
on this topic of inclusiveness i just
want to point out put in a little bit of
advice that
as you go about
doing your classes and especially if
your classes are in hybrid mode spare a
thought also for the people who are
sitting at their homes who could not
come to campus uh please include them
within your friend circle also as much
as possible okay
okay and while we are on this topic of
little bit of academics uh
i i want to i want to say the thing i i
i told you earlier that i would not be
giving any individual advice and this is
not that uh
but still somewhat okay but on the same
theme so i previously mentioned about
being kind to others being compassionate
to others at the same time don't forget
to be kind to yourself what i mean by
that is
let's say that
you are very much excited about joining
some kind of study group okay group
study is important uh and you may think
so all right but
group study is not for everyone okay so
if you're an extremely introverted
person if you suddenly go for a group
study it is not going to help you okay
try it
if it helps you great if it doesn't help
you don't try to force yourself so be a
little bit kind to yourself also now
words don't force others like if you
yourself are an extroverted person don't
force another person who may be in a
completely different mental space to
join the study group
okay
so be a little bit respectful like that
okay so whatever i've said till now is
quite uh heavy going
uh
i want to end on a slightly uh slightly
lighter note uh still important thing
so
indulge me this so this is on the on the
note of friendship okay and i got this
idea of uh of speaking about this
particular point from
a comment on the on the previous post
you may have
developed some kind of friendships
through your online interactions with
your batchmates okay and the natural
expectation is that when you come to the
campus you will continue on that
friendship that online friendship on a
much more
stronger footing once you get to know
this person okay
if that happens that's great but please
don't be surprised if it doesn't happen
okay you see
uh human interaction is rather faker
okay sometimes it's just inexplicable
so just because your friends online
doesn't mean that you're going to be
friends
in real life also it may not happen
and
on this note of friendship and i think
i'm going to say this especially
directly to the guys among you uh
if uh
you thought
that
your online interactions
uh
may lead to some kind of
a budding romantic relationship
uh
well get real okay
uh
probably not gonna happen okay
um
and just to end a little bit of a
serious note on this topic uh
you see
don't get uh don't get stressed out on
these things
friendships romantic relationships let
it happen on its own be a little bit
proactive but don't don't stress
yourself out
rather
invest some time and effort
on
being a better version of yourself
what i want to say here is that
if you work towards improving yourself
okay making yourself dependable
something which somebody which uh
others and when i say others boys girls
young old others can trust
i think that will be a much better
version of yourself so
uh
if you become such a person whom
uh you yourself love and admire
then you will see that others also will
start to love and admire and respect you
okay so on this positive note i will end
this video
a very very happy new year to all of you
and those who are about to join the
campuses all the very very best thank
you